[Music]
Mark Ballas and BC Jean have become
quite the power couple the two have
perfected the art of maintaining both a
professional and personal life together
and now they're revealing to ET how they
managed to do it all well fair enough
the pair first met back in 2012 at a
mutual friend's house when they were
both set to perform at a livestream
event BC was already on stage and I
couldn't see her I could only hear her
so by the sound of the voice I'm
expecting like this 45 year old like
whiskey-drinking Woodstock looking like
hippy yeah that's what I was expecting
but she was tearing down her gear and
and then I saw her and I was like no
that voice thing coming out of that
would cute little blonde no way I'm
actually a 40 year old whiskey drinking
hippie I just have great moisturizer
Marc got the courage to ask her out but
BC turned him down for two months
finally she agreed to go out with him he
want to go the movies I wasn't
comfortable with that I get nervous on
date things so eventually she met me for
Taco Tuesday talking to Mark's and tacos
you know whiskey Marg singing and
dancing yeah we'd hang out with them the
couple started up the group Alexandre
Jean after they wrote some songs
together a few years ago we really
enjoyed the process and we loved the
outcomes so we're like we need we should
join forces and see what we can do and
then we've been writing some songs and
next thing you know or or a duo
[Music]
you
[Music]